time to get changed
[Music]
I'm in the heart of the Delta I've
decided to disguise myself as the
lifeblood of this country an American
Farmer
[Music]
guys yeah yeah you ready man on the
table yes let's go let's start
it's time for a big old plate of that
famous southern hospitality
we're gonna kind of take a little break
before we start out tonight I'm not sure
um I sure do need it
place looks like I could do with a paint
now yeah the farmers I'm with are locals
which should help me maintain my cover
hey there how are y'all but after
spotting the Hideous Decor I'm feeling a
tad over Dressed Man time
in this kitchen and just come check out
the truth I don't know what it is but
it's some stank
holy [__] well let's test drive the
filet mignon that's the best I have to
offer meat and taters what's a tater a
tater potato
we're ordering menu items that should be
Southern Staples let me get the bowl
how's the Dumbo the fried oysters I get
a side pork chop I'm gonna try the uh
fried catfishing along with the large
filet kind of a flounder Ranch
thank you ma'am
Bean locals here would you come here
yeah we quit coming here about three
years ago we've been gone downhill
bring me your appetizers are up
yes
[Music]
thank you
greasy rubbery
I'm gonna pass on the gumbo
osters
it feels like I'm chewing a [__] golf
ball yeah I don't swallow that oyster I
stopped
banking fish
I like it
hey
uh look at that oh my nose
yeah catch the day Hepatitis B
catfish for my powder
oh my Lord you think catfish would be
exceptional wouldn't you oh that is
terrible
oh that's horrible right there man
that's not good I'm gonna get changed
okay so just uh just try and attempt to
eat please do because I'm not real sure
how long I can keep eating this
seriously
um
shocking food is embarrassing flounder
oh my Lord it was [__] grim
[Music]
time to go sightseeing morning guys
we're good
smile please everybody
my names if you play
[Music]
I'm posing as a French tourist so I can
go deep undercover yeah I lived in Paris
for three years do two years
I learned to speak French whilst
training as a chef in Paris in my early
days so this was the perfect opportunity
also on your right Fox Studios home to
The Simpsons new girl and me
I have a pretty good idea where we'll go
for lunch all right well look it looks
like one of my favorite restaurants La
Serenata let's see if they'll let us
join in the fun guys all right thank you
hopefully I won't be spotted
customers
welcome to last Saturday guys great
great thank you we got it to our nangtok
coming in Missy
yeah
this place looks great
that's it we're ordering dishes that any
Mexican restaurant worth their
margaritas and salt should be able to
make
sure
yeah we'll have that as well okay very
good one more thing yeah we'll handle
breakfast burrito thank you having seen
the practices in that kitchen for my
surveillance team
look at this I'm not expecting much
solution
see you soon
came off his [__] nose into my suit
and look look at that this spilling over
like a volcano
that tastes disgusting
[Music]
okay burrito okay
okay for the place a little bit hard
okay you have to make everybody happy
every single baby people has to be happy
with the food I don't think the food's a
problem here
to tell you what that reminds me of it's
like the inside of my great granddad's
Underpants without the Pistons
okay Mahi with the garlic I think you're
all the Mahi Lady it's here yeah no it's
here you don't like spicy right oh
that's beyond the no spicy lady okay I'm
the one who who ordered my Hima just put
the plate down okay there you go so this
is a salmon no that's mahi mahi that's
the same but it's the same thing
yours is the chili thingies and mine is
the mild ones
no composure it's just running around
like your headless chicken right I've
seen enough thank you I'll be back in a
moment okay see you later
wow so that was shocking service it's
great for Foods is embarrassing you can
feel the panic in everyone that this
place is sinking and more importantly
everyone's given up if I'm gonna help
this canine friendly place they're gonna
have to get in there and start sniffing
around so I need to go Incognito to
truly assess the situation
Kelly hi guys how are we good to see you
[Music]
good girl sit sit good girl today I'm
heading to lunch with my fellow dog
lovers and our furry friends to see how
rough things really are oh man God Carly
hey come on Mojo right this one
thank you
did you notice when we came in there was
no structure no rules dogs can be on or
off the leash yeah they didn't tell us
anything yeah wow
over this eating off the table
do you all need a few more minutes to
look it over no I think we're ready for
her I want the fur balls we're ordering
dog friendly Chow for our canine
companions we would like the tummy rub
surprise an American Classics for
ourselves chicken fried chicken and a
burger a medium bread thank you
the service come to the table and pet
the dogs
that needs to be parameters where you
follow strict guidelines how are you
doing Sue good good good deal
all right Tracy here's your dog bowls
don't be hot I'll take them
I'm going to assume this small one is
for the yes okay the fur balls thank you
wow let's put the dog food on the table
there's steam coming off of these just
touch it and the piping hot the pool
double bonus man yes ridiculous
they're all over it huh hey man don't
say nothing to me you're not perfect I
didn't say I was y'all stay down there I
got all this over here I can't do this
with a bunch of people all over my area
look at this
somebody make it not I just made it and
it just went everywhere
why do you make it wrong I'm sorry
you're heard
see I'll take one of those did you about
get a bite of that Mojo
I mean at this stage the dog food looks
way more attractive than the customers
food
hello I need a burger special just a
burger you want for us sell me a fry
you see no sick awesome BJ man look at
that it's great it's white
can't get a burger ready we're in
trouble that's gross all right listen to
my Lord
what's that
this chicken is Bland it is
dry and the gravy is shocking
oh my Lord
it's like someone's being shot oh my God
and there's a black hair it doesn't even
belong to my dog oh my Lord what is that
oh it's on the front house
that's a human hair I actually look you
can even see where it came off of her
head
there's hat everywhere whatever the food
yes how are you look at you he's so
pretty and who is this this is Cece Cece
yes well my dog's dog is named Susie but
it stands for Christmas cookies
well you guys thanks for coming out
appreciate it
wow there's more hair in my food than
you just put on my chin
ah yo yo that's terrible